we've been recently getting some  bombshell leaks for the upcoming macbook  air ross young saying that we should  expect a new 15 inch  macbook air in  2023 which is absolutely mind-blowing  and digitimes confirming that apple is  gonna be launching the new redesigned  macbook air in the second half of 2022  now as far as the actual features and  specs that we should be expecting from  the new redesigned macbook air we should  first and foremost expect the new m2  chip and mark german thinks the m2 is  gonna come with an eight cpu core layout  but as far as the graphic scores it's  gonna be jumping from seven or eight to  nine or 10 graphic scores i think the  redesigned macbook air is coming in the  fall  october or november with the m2 chip  with white bezels a notch white keyboard  just like i showed you guys and these  renders i think is going to be  absolutely beautiful